-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
I'm going to get to the news.
The White House announced today
that President Biden's aides
found classified documents
at several locations
inside his Delaware home.
And he's had them for a while,
because a lot of them have to do
with the Louisiana Purchase.
That's right --
The White House announced
that President Biden's aides
found classified documents
at several
locations at his house,
including in the garage,
next to his vintage Corvette.
And this isn't great --
it's The White House's corvette.
According to a new book,
then-president Trump
discussed, in 2017,
the possibility of striking
North Korea
with a nuclear weapon
and then blaming it
on another country.
Even weirder, he wanted to
blame it on Belgium.
"Why would we do such a thing?"
[ Laughter ]
That's --
"We don't even have the means!"
That's right -- Trump discussed
the possibility of
striking North Korea
with a nuclear weapon and then
blaming it on another country.
Oh, my God, seriously?
It's a nuclear war, not a fart.
[ As Trump ] It's worked before,
on a smaller scale.
I've beta-tested this plan
a few times."
[ Normal voice ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
announced yesterday
that he has demoted
the top military commander
in Ukraine
and brought in a replacement.
But you know what they say --
every time God closes a door,
Putin opens
a fourth-story window.
[ Laughter ]
My Pillow C.E.O. Mike Lindell
said this week
that he has locked in
enough votes to become chairman
of the
Republican National Committee.
Apparently,
he has the support of over
60% of the voices in his head.
According to a new book,
White House
intelligence officials
were concerned that
then-president Trump
repeatedly failed to use
secure phone lines
because North Korea
could be listening
in on his calls.
Said Trump, "It's fine.
It's actually who I'm calling."
Former North Carolina
Congressman Madison Cawthorn
has reportedly moved to Florida.
So he's gone from the
youngest person in Congress
to the youngest person
in Florida.
The fast-food chain White Castle
has announced
it will offer Valentine's Day
dinner service,
which will end in both a
figurative
and literal broken heart.
In her first public appearance
since the release of
Prince Harry's memoir, "Spare,"
Princess Kate Middleton
was seen driving a car yesterday
outside Windsor Castle.
So it looks like we caught Harry
in his first lie.
A California man
recently got out of his car
to take a phone call
and returned to find the vehicle
had been crushed by a boulder.
I think we have a picture
of the guy?
And, finally,
according to a new study,
Puerto Rican forest lizards
have gone through
recent genetic changes in order
to survive in urban areas,
like they know to turn white
when a cop's coming.
That was the monologue,
everybody.
That's the last one.